[Music]
here's all the latest in royal baby news
Buckingham Palace crowd emails the birth
of a new debone Royal Prince Kate
Middleton and Prince William introduced
their newborn son to the world on Monday
posing for photos outside the window
wing of st. Mary's Hospital in London
just hours after Kate gave birth to
their third child per usual the 36 year
old Duchess stunned wearing a red dress
while cradling her baby and weaving to
the crowd
the Duke stood by her side donning a
blue suit the same shade four year old
George and two year old Charlotte wore
to honor their new brother when will
brought them to the hospital to meet him
check out that smile Charlotte flashed
the media before heading inside it seems
she already has this royal thing down a
good thing considering the young
princess made history on Monday becoming
the first female heir to the throne to
supersede her younger male sibling in
the line of succession
thanks to Allah put into place in 2011
Charlotte is now fourth in line to the
throne preceded by her grandpa Prince
Charles who will eventually secede the
92 year old queen second in line as
Charlotte's daddy Prince William then
comes her eldest brother George
Charlotte's new baby bro has assumed the
position of fifth in line which knocks
Prince Harry down to 6 no word on
whether the 33 year-old has met his new
nephew just yet he and fiance Megan
Markel were not spotted at the hospital
on Monday instead they attended the 25th
anniversary memorial service
commemorating Stephen Lawrence and next
on the royal agenda the couple's May
19th wedding
[Music]
[Applause]